[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار اسهلها بابره
210 ساعات على زلزاله تركيا وسوريا حصيله
الضحايا تلامس 41 الف قتيل وفرق الانقاذ
تعثر على مزيد من الناجين
وعلى راسهم الاطفال تحذيراتهم من امراض
جسديه وصدمات نفسيه قد تلاحق الناجين من
الزلزال
مرتزقه تضيق الخناق على باخموت وواشنط
تتوقع مفاجاه اوكرانيا ومفاجاه مضاده في
الربيع
بعد سير من الاتهامات البيت الابيض يستبعد
ارتباط الاجسام التي تم اسقاطها ببرنامج
التجسس الصيني
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الكارثه التي تسبب
بها الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا والماساه
التي خلفها وراءه عدد الضحايا اقترب من 41
الف قتيل ففي الجانب التركي من حدود
الزلزال وصل العدد الى حوالي 36 الف قتيل
اما الجانب السوري فكانت حصته حتى الان
5000 واربعمائه وسبعه عشر قتيلا وهنا
نتحدث حتى الان كون الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع سيما معا انخفاض فرصه العثور على
مزيد من الناجين الذين لم تغب عمليات
انقاذم حتى اليوم وحتى هذه الساعه تجرى
هذه العمليات لانقاذ عائله سوريه كامله
فيها طايا التركيه جرى اجلاء اثنين منها
ويتم العمل على اخراج باقي افراد العائله
ومع مرور طبعا اكثر من 210 ساعات على وقوع
الكارثه
عده اشخاص خرجوا احياء من تحت الانقاض في
تركيا
قهرمان مرعش بؤره الزلزال واكثر المدن
المدمره سجلت ابرز هذه الحالات
[موسيقى]
الطفله السوريه لينا وامها كانتان ناجيتين
الابرز خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه
محمد انيس هو الاخر كتبت له الحياه بعد
198 ساعه عاشها تحت الركام
كذلك هذا الشاب الذي يبلغ 18 عاما وصلت
اليه فرق الانقاذ وهو بصحه جيده
وبعد 203 ساعات استطاع المنقذون انتشال
هذه السيده على قيد الحياه بمدينه هاتاي
[موسيقى]
جميع علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان الزلزال
الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي حدثت في
العالم وقدروا قوته بقوه مئات القنابل
الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون للشفاء
في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده الزلازل
ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه استثنائيه
اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عدده وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
اطلق الامين العام لمنظمه الامم المتحده
انطونيو نداء انسانيا لجمع نحو 400 مليون
دولار لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
اوضح ايضا ان المبلغ المساعدات سيغطي فتره
ثلاثه اشهر مشيرا الى ان المنظمه تعمل على
اطلاق نداء مماثل للتبرع لضحايا الزلزال
في تركيا واضاف جورج ان ما يقارب تسعه
ملايين شخص في سوريا تضرروا بسبب الزلزال
هذا وبعد السيل من الانتقادات ولاول مره
منذ وقوع الزلزال المدمر دخل اول وفد
للامم المتحده الى مناطق الزلازل التي
تسيطر عليها المعارضه في شمال غربي سوريا
زياره الوفد لسوريا تهدف الى تقييم
الاضرار جراء الزلزال وفق مسؤول الاممي في
جناف هذا وقد عبر الوفد وعبر ايضا معبر
باب الهوى بين تركيا وسوريا الى محافظه
ادلب ثم الى مدينه سرمدا
[موسيقى]
بعد اعترافهم بانهم قصروا بحق السوريين
دخل اول وفد اممي الشمال السوري عبر معبر
باب الهوى الى ادلب اسبوعنا مضى على حادثه
الزلزال المدمر شمالي سوريا انشا حاله غضب
شعبي واسعه طالت الامم المتحده وجعلت
الشعور بالخذلان اقوى من ان تبرره الكلمات
مارتن جرافيث وكيلو الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه اعتبر ان
السوريين محقون في مشاعر الخذلان التي
اصابتهم ملمحا الى نيه المؤسسه الامميه
تصحيح الفشل سريعا الوفد الذي بدا زيارته
بالاعتراف بخزلان خمسه ملايين السوري شمال
غربي سوريا رافقته 26 شاحنه من المساعدات
الانسانيه ووفق مصادر العربيه سيبدا الوفد
بتقييم الاضرار وتحديد الاحتياجات في
محاوله لتعويض ما يراه السوريون حقا
انسانيا تاخر وصوله نداءات سوريه للعمل من
خارج مجلس الامن لافتتاح ثلاثه معابر
باسرع وقت
موعودون ان شاء الله ان هذه القوافل ستكبر
بشكل اكثر خلال الايام القادمه بحيث تغطي
اكبر احتياج لاهلنا الذين تضرروا من
الزلزال
ملف المعابر في سوريا لطالما كان محطه
تجاذبات سياسيه بين دول حليفه للنظام
واخرى داعمه للشعب السوري ليتحول الى ورقه
ضغط سياسي بين الاطراف في اروقه مجلس
الامن ومع تفاقم ازمه النازحين الى
المخيمات اقر مجلس الامن قبل 9 سنوات
السماح بعبور المساعدات الانسانيه الامميه
من اربعه معابر بريه في سوريا هي باب
السلامه وباب الهوى مع تركيا ولي عروبيه
مع العراق والرمثا مع الاردن وفي مطلع عام
2020 صوت مجلس الامن لقرار عبور المساعدات
الامميه عبر تركيا من خلال معبري باب
الهواء وباب السلامه ما تسبب في اغلاق
معبرين في شمال شرقي وجنوب سوريا حنان
المصري العربيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من ادلب الصحافه مسلم
السيد عيسى مسلم يعني نقلت طيله الايام
الماضيه الصوره من هناك المساعدات
الانسانيه التي وصلت هل هي كافيه حتى
الساعه وماذا عن مراكز الايواء وما الذي
يحتاجه اليوم السوريين بهذه المناطق
في الحقيقه يعني جزء المساعدات التي دخلت
شاحنه اليوم الجديد الذي بدات فيه دخول
الشاحنات بدات طبعا هذه الحاله بالتحسن
بشكل تدريجي انا اتحدث عن المعابر
الحدوديه مع تركيا لمناطق شمال وشمال غرب
سوريا هذه الشاحنات اغلبها كانت من الامم
المتحده حيث دخلت باعداد كبيره حقيقه يوم
امس واليوم عبر معبر باب الهوى خصوصا مع
زياده الوفد الاممي وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك
يعني تحسن في دخول المساعدات لكن المؤسسات
الانسانيه هنا تقول ان
نوعيه المساعدات التي تدخل الى المنطقه
تحتاج الى دراسه وفقا للمعطيات التي
تقدمها والاحتياجات التي تقدمها المنظمات
على الارض لان الاحتياج الان بشكل اساسي
لتجاوز المرحله الكارثيه هو فقط لمواد
التدفئه والمواد العاجله ثم الى
سماح المنظمات سماح الامم المتحده
للمنظمات ببناء القرى السكنيه وهذا وهناك
وهذه نقطه مهمه حقيقه لان تواصلت مع
الكثير من المؤسسات الان هنا على الارض
التي تعمل كشريك للامم المتحده هناك قانون
لدى الامم المتحده يمنع باعاده الاعمار او
بناء الكره السكنيه في المناطق هنا شمال
وشمال غرب سوريا لانها تعتبرها توطين
للنازحين وبالتالي يعني يبدو انه حكم على
هؤلاء النازحين بالعيش بالخيام لسنوات
طويله
يعني عملا بهذا القانون الذي تتحدث عنه
اليوم نحن امام ظرف استثنائي وامام كارثه
طبيعيه استثنائيه اليس هناك اي يعني ماده
بهذا القانون تستثني شيء لهؤلاء خصوصا ان
الحل السياسي ربطا بهذا القانون طويل
يعني ما نشاهده على الارض هو التزام بهذا
المبدا او القانون لان يبدو ان هذا يعني
تجاوز هذه القانون يعرض المؤسسات الشريكه
للامم المتحده
لربما منح من المساعدات او غيرها لكن هناك
بدائل تعمل على الارض وهي عبر المؤسسات
الحكوميه العربيه سواء السعوديه او
القطريه او الكويتيه للعمل على بناء الشقق
والقرى السكنيه العاجله او حتى الكرفانات
البلاستيكيه وغيرها لايواء هؤلاء النازحين
هذه النقطه جدا مهمه توضيحها ان يعني
نتحدث نحن عن شمال السوري فقط عندنا فقط
واحد فاصله ثمانيه مليون نازح واكثر من
اربعه مليون شخص في بقعه جغرافيه كانت قبل
عشر سنوات تحوي فقط وبافضل حال مليون ونصف
وبالتالي التضخم السكاني هنا في المنطقه
وتجميع السوريين في هذه المنطقه سيسبب
كارثه انسانيه وازمه خصوصا مع
ايضا يعني ممكن ان يتسبب بامراض
او بهذه النقطه المساعدات الطبيه هل وصلت
وفود طبيه جديده خصوصا ان يعني هناك نقص
هائل وفادح بهذا القطاع يعني خصوصا
يعني مناشدات المنظمات العامله بالقطاع
الصحي قالت انها تحتاج الى نقطتين اول
المحروقات والديزل الى المستشفيات لانها
كانت في الفتره اليومين الماضيين قد نفذت
مواردها الخاصه بهذا الموضوع لتشغيل
المستشفيات والنقطه الثانيه الكوادر
الطبيه للاعمال الجراحيه التخصصيه نتيجه
يعني هنا الحاجه الى هذه الكوادر ما دخل
حتى اللحظه هي ثلاث كوادر طبيه جاءت مع
مؤسسات تركيه عبر متطوعين من الاطباء حول
العالم ووصلوا وبداوا العمل في المستشفيات
لكن لا اعتقد ان هذه يعني الثغره ستسد عبر
قدوم بعض الاطباء وغيرها نحن نتحدث عن
مستشفيات اليوم دخلت الى اكثر من مستشفى
خصوصا في المناطق المتضرره من بلده حارم
وجنديرس وغيرها
المستشفيات يعني تغص بالجرحى الاحصائيه
الاخيره التي صدرت اليوم للدفاع المدني
اتحدث فقط عن شمال غير سوريا تتحدث عن
اثني عشر الف واربع مئه مصاب فقط في هذه
المنطقه كنا قبل يومين فقط نتحدث عن خمسه
الاف يعني ارتفعت الحصيله بشكل مفاجئ الى
12,400 مصابه وبالتالي هؤلاء المصابون
اغلبهم بحالات كسور بحالات تحتاج الى تدخل
طبي مساعدات بالادويه وغيرها وهذه
المستشفيات هي بالاصل يعني قطاع الصحي في
المنطقه
ليس فقط وانما ايضا للاستشفاء اما داخل
سوريا او خارج سوريا واما سيرتفع اعداد
القتلى لان من نشا مع يعني صد النفسيه
وجسديه ممكن ان يفقد حياته بالايام
المقبله شكرا لك من ادلب الصحافي مسلم
السيد عيسى على رساله اليوم وعلى كل
الرسائل التي وفيتنا بها منذ وقوع هذه
الكارثه وحتى هذه الساعه
[موسيقى]
عائلته غنام السوريه لم يبقى احد منها كي
يبكي عليها الزلزال المدمر قضى على جميع
افرادها في مدينه عزمارين بريف ادلب واحد
وخمسون شخصا من عائله غنام تهدمت بيوتهم
فوق رؤوسهم حيث تم انتشالهم من تحت
الانقاض وركام المبادئ المهدمه فيها قصه
عائله غنام التي فطرت قلب من حولهم او حتى
من وصله الخبر ستضاف الى قصص ماسي عائلات
اخرى بعضها عرف مصيرها والبعض الاخر لم
يعرف بعد ناشطون على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تداولوا اسماء عائلات غنام
المغدوره الواحد والخمسين كي يخلدوا ويخلد
ذكرهم
تصارع مناطق شمال وغرب سوريا اثار الزلزال
المدمره ما بين تحدي كبير
تكابده وايضا فرق الانقاذ بين الركام
والتحدي الاكبر الذي قد يتمثل بارسال
معونات عبر الحدود البريه التي تمتلكها
سوريا والتي قد تقف حائلا بين وصول
المساعدات للنازحين في ظل النزاع السياسي
بين القوى المتصارعه
نجوا بمعجزه من بين تلك الانقاض في سوريا
اثرى نوبه زلزال مدمر لكنهم في امس الحاجه
للمساعدات بكافه اشكالها وسط مساع امميه
لادخال الاعانات برا الى سوريا التي تمتلك
ما لا يقل عن عشره معابر حدوديه حيث تترقب
كل من الولايات المتحده والمانيا تنفيذا
النظام السوري قرار فتحي معبريبه بالسلام
والراعي لمرور الاعانات الانسانيه الا ان
الانقسامات السياسيه قد تعرقل جهود
الاغاثه ففي شمال غربي البلاد تسيطر هيئه
تحرير الشام على محافظه ادلب كما ان هناك
منطقتين تسيطر عليهما عده فصائل تدعمهما
تركيا ابرزها الجيش الوطني السوري اضافه
الى منطقه الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرقي
سوريا التي يتزعمها الاكراد بقياده قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه اما دمشق وبقيه المدن
فهي خاضعه للنظام السوري ومن ابرز ما عبر
سوريا من جهه تركيا باب الهوى الخاضع
لسيطره هيئه تحرير الشام اما معبر باب
السلام والحمام وجرابلس والراعي فترتبط
بين تركيا ومناطق في شمال وشرقي محافظه
حلب تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه المدعومه
من قبل انقره
كل نقاط العبور تلك باعبائها وازماتها
وحجم النزاع بين المسيطرين عليها دفعت
مسؤولا بلجنه الانقاذ الدوليه للقول ان
الزلازل لا تعترف بتلك الحدود
استطاعت فرق الانقاذ التركيه من استخراج
طفل يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما وذلك من تحت
الانقاد في اديه مان بعدما بقي هناك لاكثر
من 200 وسبع ساعات فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايبن معبر باب
الهوى مازن علوش مدير العلاقات الاعلاميه
والمتحدث باسم اداره معبر باب الهوى استاذ
مازن كيف هي الصوره اليوم من المعبر خصوصا
ان المساعدات الامميه بدات تصل اكثر فاكثر
ماذا عن المساعدات الاخرى هل هناك هل
تلقيتم يعني اي مساعدات غير المساعدات
الامميه التي رصدناها اليوم
مساء الخير
المساعدات القادمه من الامم المتحده لليوم
السادس على التوالي وصلتنا اليوم قافله
مؤلفه من 26 شاحنه محمد
المستندات الاضافيه لاهلنا المنكوبين
اضافه الى المساعدات الامميه طبعا ترافق
دخول مساعدات الامميه دخول وفد من الامم
المتحده
جاء الى المناطقنا للاطلاع على الاوضاع في
بعض الزلزال ايضا دخلت قافله من الجمعيات
الخيريه التركيه مؤلفه من قرابه 15 شاحنه
محمد مختلف مواد دراسيه تم تجوعها على
اهلنا المنكوبين في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
هذا كل ما وصلنا اليوم اجمالي ما وصلنا من
بعد الزلزال من الامم المتحده بلغت حصيله
الشاحنات ورابط 84 شاحنه فقط وهي كميه
قليله جدا لا تكفي احتياج ولا حتى 1% من
الاهالي المنكوبين من جراء الزلزال نحن لا
نتحدث فقط يعني عن احتياجات
غذائيه نتحدث عن احتياجات لمعدات لرفع
الركام لم يصلكم اي شيء منها طبعا حتى
الساعه حسب ما اعلمتمون قبل معدات طبيه هل
وصل اي شيء
سوى البارحه كمادات طبيه البارحه
ارسلت دوله قطر قافله طبيه مؤلفه من سبعه
شاحنات تحتوي على معدات طبيه بالاضافه
لفريق طبي مكون من خمسه عشر طبيب هم الان
لدينا في منطقه ادلب يقومون عن طريق
الهلال الاحمر القطري يقومون باجراء
العمليات الجراحيه
المرضى ايضا دخلنا اليوم بوابه الطبي من
15 طبيب سوريين مقيمين في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا جاؤوا لمساعده
زملائهم الاطباء في علاج المراه
بحاجه لاكبر بكثير من هذا العدد للقيام
باللازم اريد ان انوه الامر نحن قبل
الزلزال كل الحارات المرضيه الصعبه
كنا نقوم بارسالها عبر معبر باب الهواء
للعلاج في مشافي التركيه بعد حادثه
الزلزال الجانب التركي اوقف ادخال المرضى
بشكل كامل اي حاله اسعافيه او بارده او
مرضى السرطان او مرضى الفشل الكلوي او
القلب توقفت بشكل نهائي فاصبح كبير علينا
بانتظار هذا
مناطقنا يعني المشافي لدينا تفتقر كل هذه
المعدات وتفتقر ايضا لكل شيء لدينا حاليا
2000 مريض من السرطان
موجودون في منطقه لا يوجد لديهم جرعات
للعلاج بالاضافه اكثر من 1500 مريض فشل
كلوي ومثله من مرضى القلب فكلهم كانوا
يخرجون العلاج في تركيا توقف الامر نحن
الان لدينا مشافي لكن لا يوجد فيها معدات
ولا يوجد فيها مستندات
اعاده تجهيز هذه المشافي والمراكز الطبيه
شكرا لك استاذ مازن علوش مدير العلاقات
الاعلاميه والمتحدث باسم اداره معبر باب
الهوى على هذه الرساله
وينضم الينا ايضا مشاهدينا من مدينه سرمدا
شمال ادلب ادلب منير المصطفى نائب مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري استاذ منير يعني
طبعا بالاضافه الى كل هذه المساعدات التي
لا تعتبر شيء نظرا للحاجات الموجوده هناك
كيف هو الوضع على الارض ما الذي يحتاج
اليه الدفاع المدني السوري اليوم
نعم في الحقيقه الدفاع المدني هو وصل
لمرحله للمرحله النهائيه حاليا من انتشال
الجثث من تحت الانقراض وهو يقوم في بهذه
العمليه لم يبقى الا يعني بعض الحالات
التي يتم ابلاغ عناصر الدفاع المدني
بوجودها تحت نقاط او بفقدانها ليس بتاكيد
وجودها تحت هذه الانقاذ ويتم اعاده البحث
تحت هذه الانقراض للعثور على هؤلاء
الاشخاص فنحن يعني نقول اننا بالمراحل
النهائيه من هذا العمل طبعا يرافق هذا
العمل الان عمليه فتح الطرقات التي
تم اغلاقها او اغلقت بجراء الانهيارات
الحاصله من اجل ايصال المساعدات الى من
اجل ايصال المساعدات الى من يحتاجها في من
الاشخاص الذين تعرضوا الى اضرار هذا
الزلزال طبعا هذه المرحلتين هي تترافق هذه
المرحلتين مع بعضهم بالنسبه للاحتياجات
الدفاع المدني هي للاسف هي احتياجات كثيره
للمعدات الهندسيه الثقيله التي تساعد يعني
لها اكثر من استخدام الاستخدام الاول هو
تساعد فرق الدفاع المدني والفوز بيضاء
برفع الانقراض وسحب العالقين الاحياء تحت
هذه الانقاظ وتساعد ايضا في بسحب الجثث من
تحت هذه الانقاظ وتكون ايضا هي كفيله
بامور بموضوع فتح الطرقات ناجي الايصال
المساعدات التي باتت تدخل وان كانت لا
زالت للحد الادنى ولكن بدات تدخل الى
الضالين من جراء هذا الزلزال وياتي مرحله
لاحقه هي ازاله هذه ازاله هذه الانقاض
وتهيئه البناء التحتيه هذه الاليات كلها
تستخدم في كل هذه المراحل للاسف لا زالت
يعني هي احتياج حقيقي عند فريق الدفاع
المدني هناك وعود بان هذا الاحتياج سيتم
تلبيته ونحن يعني الان هناك تواصلات مع
العديد من الاطراف والدول هي بالاساس هي
دول المانحه لفريق البيضاء من اجل استكمال
هذه النواقص نملك جزء من هذه الاليات ولكن
حجم الدمار الذي حصل يعني جراء هذا
الزلزال يعني يحتاج الى امكانيات اكبر
بكثير من الامكانيات المتوفره بين يدينا
لك استاذ منيره المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري على هذه المداخله
في قهرمان مرعش ما تزال ردود او ردم
المباني ورجوم المباني التي خلفها الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه تحتفظ بداخلها
باغراض الراحلين وذكرياتهم في مشهد مؤلم
قد يستمر لاشهر قبل ان تنجح السلطات في
ازاله اثار الكارثه مفضل العربيه الى هناك
غسان ابو اللوز والمزيد من التفاصيل في
التقرير التالي
تدخل كارثه الزلزال في تركيا اسبوعها
الثاني ونتحدث عن عشرات الالاف من القتلى
ومن المصابين ونتحدث عن اخرين ما زالوا
يحاولون انقاذهم من تحت الانقاذ رغم تضاؤل
فرص النجاح هذه الانقاض لفظت كل الحياه من
داخلها لاصحابها
ولفظت ايضا ذكرياتهم التي حرصوا على
تسجيلها نشاهد الان من بين هذه الانقاذ
عشرات ربما مئات الصور على الاقل في هذا
المكان لسكان هذا المجمع السكني ولا نريد
اظهار اشكالهم في صور احتراما لخصوصيتهم
هذا هو الوضع التي الذي يمكن ان نشاهده
بين المباني المدمره في كهرمان مرعش الحال
مؤلم جدا والوضع سيء جدا كما نشاهد كتب
لطلاب وتلاميذ
واطفال كانوا ربما يستعدون لدرس اخر في
يوم اخر لكن كل ذلك بات اثرا بعد عين كما
نشاهد
غساله العربيه كهرمان مرعش
مشاهدينا اتابع واياكم هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليه انقاذ عائله مكونه من سبعه اشخاص
في مدينه هاتايا التركيه حتى الساعه تم
انتشال شخصين من تحت الالقاد وهم بحاله
جيده كما افادنا مراسلنا قبل قليل بانتظار
معرفه مصير الخمسه المتبقين تحت هذه
الانقاد اذا اليوم هو اليوم يعني التاسع
بعد هذا الزلزال نحن نتحدث عن يعني معجزه
بالبقاء تحت الانقاض حتى هذا اليوم هناك
حالات ما زالت حتى الساعه يتم ايجاده ويتم
انتشاله من تحت هذه الاوقات بالرغم من كل
الصعوبات الموجوده هناك وبالرغم من
الحالات الطقس
الصعبه وبالرغم ايضا من حاله الانهيار
الكبيره التي اصابت هذه المباني جراء
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب هذه المناطق
التركيه نتحدث عن عشر ولايات تركيه تقريبا
بشكل شبه كامل بسبب قوه هذا الزلزال اذا
نحن بانتظار معرفه مصير من تبقى من هذه
العائله لمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا عبد
المحسن الحربي مفرد العربيه من تركيا عبد
المحسن
بالفعل كل فرق الانقاذ او اغلب فرق
الانقاذ الدوليه على الاقل هنا في غازي
عنتاب وفي المدن الاخرى تم توجيهها الى
انطاكيا نظرا للحاج الكبيره جدا في
المباني
المهدمه التي وصل عددها الى 2000 من اصل
47 الف مبنى متضرر في انحاء هذه
المناطق جنوبي تركيا في العشر ولايات التي
تضررت بشكل كبير فبالتالي يتم او بعد هذه
التعزيزات التي وصلت من فرق الانقاذ
الدوليه التي وصلت الى تلك المنطقه تم
العمل على البحث عن ناجين في مناطق مختلفه
وايضا بالرغم من ذلك لم تصل فرق الانقاذ
الى بعض المناطق التي هنالك ربما يستبع
بوجود ناسين او حتى بوجود انتشال الجثث من
تلك المناطق في انطاكيا كانت هنالك مشاهد
ماساويه لاشخاص تحدثت اليهم قاد من
انطاكيا وانا موجود الان في غازي عنتاب
قالوا بان مشاهد الجثث متراميه على
الاطراف
المدينه لا تزال موجوده الكثير ينتظر ذويه
في المنازل التي هي مهدمه اما يتم العمل
عليها او يستغيثون بشكل كامل
للعمل عليها على الاقل لاستخراج الجثه
والنظر بنظره اخيره الى ذويهم قبل دفنهم
عبد المحسن بغازي عنتاب هل يمكن القول ان
الامل فقد هناك بايجاد يعني ناجين تحت
الانقاض
في غازي عنتاب اكثر اكثر منطقتين تظللت هي
الابراهيملي والاكثر منها هي اصلاحيه لا
تزال فرق الانقاذ تعمل ولكن بشكل
اقل بقليل بكثير من الايام الماضيه في
منطقه ابراهيم لي الفرق الدوليه غادرتها
بشكل كامل وتبقيت بعض الفرق التركيه التي
تريد ان تنتشر الجثث بعد التاكد من عدم
وجود احياء في تلك المنطقه والتاكد من
وجود فقط جثث بالاضافه الى اصلاحيه هي يتم
العمل على انتشال الجثث في ذلك تلك
المنطقه في الحقيقه كنت قبل قليل في زياره
الى مقر ومكان انطلاق هذا الزلزال
كهرمان كهرمان التي انطلق منها هذا
الزلزال ورايت ايضا بعض
المناظر في تركيا المدينه الشبه يعني
خاليه عدم من الحركه البسيطه جدا
والاحياء بشكل شبه كامل فارغه الجميع توجه
الى مناطق العامه تحديدا في استاذ كهرمان
الذي يتواجد في عشرات الاسر التي نزحت الى
ذلك المكان للمكوث فيه واستقبال المساعدات
الاغاثيه الدوليه والماليه
غير معلوم مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من غازي
عنتاب في تركيا على كل حال مشاهدينا سنعود
بعد قليل لمتابعه حال هذه العائله على امل
ان يتم لم شمله بما ان معظم العائلات بهذا
الزلزال اما ان شردت واما ان فقدت بكاملها
حياتها تحت هذه الاوقات تتابعون في
التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
استمرار اغلاق المعابر الداخليه في سوريا
بوجه المساعدات الرسميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد مرور ثمانيه ايام
على كارثه الزلزال لا تزال المعابر
الداخليه بين مناطق الاكراد والنظام
والمعارضه في شمال شرق سوريا مغلقه في وجه
المساعدات الرسميه وهو ما يعرقل حركه هذه
المساعدات ووصولها الى المناطق المنكوبه
100 شاحنه وقود لا تزال عالقه هنا في معبر
التائهه قدمتها الاداره ذاتيه كمساعدات
للسكان المنكوبين في محافظه حلب رغم
الحاجه الماسه الى الوقود في مناطق النظام
لم تفضي المفاوضات بين الجانبين الى اي
نتيجه النظام اشترط الحصول على حصه الاسد
منها فرفض الاكراد واصروا على ايصالها
بانفسهم الى المنكوبين يتكرروا مشهد وقوف
الشاحنات في التائهه في معبر ام جلود ايضا
حيث علقت ثلاثون شاحنه اخرى يقول الاكراد
ان لا شرط او قيد لتسليمها الى المعارضه
ويامل السوريون ان تفتح المعابر امام
مساعدات الاداره مثل ما فتحت امام مساعدات
الاهالي التي نجحت في ادخال 119 شاحنه عبر
معبر ام جلود وعون الدادات المعابر
الداخليه تشهد فصلا جديدا من معارك
البوتخاصمين وتغلق امام السوريين
المنكوبين في المناطق المتضرره فرص الحصول
على الدعم من سوريين اخرين يحملون نفس
الهويه من معبر التائهه في مدينه منبج
شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش لقناتي العربيه
والحدث
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات الزلزال ايضا تاثر اكثر من
سبعه ملايين طفل بالزلزال والمدمر والهزات
الارتداديه الكبيره التي اعقبته في تركيا
وسوريا الاسبوع الماضي وفقا طبعا ما اعلنت
الامم المتحده وقال المتحدث باسم منظمه
اليونيسف ان مجموع الاطفال الذين يعيشون
في المحافظات العشر التركيه التي ضربها
الزلزالان بلغ اربعه فاصله سته مليون طفل
وفي سوريا بلغ اثنين فاصله خمسه مليون طفل
واشار الى ان المنظمه تخشى مقتل الاف
الاطفال وان التقديرات تؤكد ان الاعداد
اعداد ستستمر في الازدياد
[موسيقى]
اذا صدمات نفسيه وجسديه كبيره خلفها
الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا من فقدان
الاحبه والاهل ورعب وقوع الزلازل والبقاء
مشردين ومخاوف من ما بعد الزلزال كنتشار
الاوبئه اضافه الى ظروف اخرى من شانها ان
تفاقم من هذه الازمه دعونا نبدا مشاهدينا
اولا من ان عدد المتضررين من جراء الزلزال
المدمر بلغ نحو 26 مليون شخص بينهم نحو
سبعه ملايين طفل في كل من سوريا وتركيا
وتعرضت الاف الابنيه اما للدمار كليا او
جزئيا وبالتالي عشرات الاف المشردين بدون
ماوى على جانبي الحدود والصدمه النفسيه
وفقا لاطباء الصحه النفسيه فهي تتوزع على
ثلاث مراحل الاولى هي الصدمه المباشره
والمفاجئه لحظه حدوث الزلزال وهي الجزء
الاسوا المرحله الثانيه هي عند الخروج اما
المرحله الثالثه فهي عند ايجاد المتضرر
نفسه بدون نفسه بدون ماوى وبدون اهل مع
المي فراق الاحباء ومن شان هذه الكارثه ان
تخلق لدى الكثير من المتضررين
رهاب الزلزال ورهاب الزلازل وبعض انواع
اضطراب المزاج مثل الاكتئاب واضطراب ما
بعد الشده وهو ما قد يتمثل بكوابيس لدى
الاطفال والكبار اضافه الى احتمال متلازمه
دوار ما بعد الزلزال التي قد تحدث للاشخاص
الناجين الذين استشعروا الزلازل والهزات
والموجات الارتداديه فيحدث عندهم دوار
دوخه لمده اسبوع او اسبوعين بعد زلزال
الامر الذي يتطلب متابعه دائمه للعنايه
الطبيه النفسيه الى جانب الطبيه الجسديه
سيما للاطفال وهو ما يحتاج طبعا قبل ذلك
توفر الكوادر الطبيه النفسيه المتدربه
والمجهزه لهكذا حالات
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من القاهره الدكتوره
رضوى سعيد عبد العظيم استشاره الطب النفسي
دكتوره رضوى يعني هنا بدا كل الخبراء
يتحدثون عن شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر لاحتماليه
ان يتخطى جزء من هذه الصدمه من تعرضوا
لهذا الزلزال هل نتحدث هنا عن صدمه جماعيه
ام صدمه فرديه وكيف يمكن علاجه
حضرتك احنا هنا بنتكلم على صدمه جماعيه ثم
صدمه فرديه احنا مش بنتكلم على
حادث بسيط احنا عندنا السبعه مليون طفل
وزاويهم لحضرتك اشرتي اليهم دول صدمه
مباشره وغالبا معظمهم هيعانوا بعد كده زي
ما حضرتك وضحتي من
رهاب ما بعد صدمه اللي هو معناه حاله قلق
شديد
استرجاع للاحداث كانه شريط ما بيخلصش مع
ضربات قلب مع نوبات فزع مع اضطرابات في
النوم وجميع الاعراض الفسيولوجيه اللي
بتحصل من
رهاب ما بعد الكرب او ما بعد الصدمه
اوردر
فالحل هنا زي ما اشارتي انه لازم يكون في
تدخل من
الاطباء
ومهمين جدا الاطباء لانه كتير من الاعراض
دي ممكن ان احنا نتفاداها لو اخدنا
الادويه المناسبه سريعا ما بعد التعرض
للزلزال بحيث ان احنا نوقف الدواير اللي
هتتخلق جوه المخ من انها تتعمل
استاذه رضوى مهم جدا هنا نعم
اسمحي لي يعني ان اركز على موضوع الاطفال
عاده الاطفال يتاثرون اكثر بالصدمات
النفسيه من البالغين طبعا البالغين
يتاثرون ايضا بشكل كبير ولكن هنا نتحدث عن
اطفال بعمر صغير تنطبع بذاكرتهم كل هذه
الاحداث وتبقى يعني حتى حتى يصبحون
الراشدين كيف يمكن ان يتعاطى اهل مع
الاطفال عبر اخبارهم بما حدث عبر عبر ماذا
خصوصا ان يعني صدمه مستمره هون بدون ماوى
بدون اي شيء
مهم جدا هو وجود دعم حتى للاهالي يعني
حضرتك كل من هم في الدايره اللي تعرضت
للزلزال هم متاثرين بدهم فالدوائر كلها
لازم تحمي بعض يعني
المجموعه
والعمليات الانقاذ اللي فيها
متخصصين اطباء نفسيين لازم تساعد
المساعدين يعني الاب السليم الخاله اللي
لم تتوفى من جراء الزلزال كل دول لازم
يدعموا نفسيا عشان يعرفوا يدعموا الاطفال
لان دعمهم هيحتاج وقت اطول فهنا المجموعه
كلها لازم تتضافر اللي جوه مع البر ده رقم
واحد رقم اثنين قلتي الاطفال بيتاثروا
اكتر الحقيقه كمان انه في بعض البالغين
بيكونوا اكثر تاثرا من من يعني مش كل
الناس زي بعض في ناس بيبقى عندها مرونه
نفسيه وعندها قدره على تحمل
اكتر من اخرين فبتبتدي تظهر اعراض القلق
والاضطراب النفسي اقدر ودول لازم يتلحقوا
برضو زيهم زي الاطفال كتير من الاطفال
اللي تعرضوا للصدمات مش بس الزلزال يعني
عندنا كمان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه الاطفال
هناك استفادوا من الضرب والقنابل وكل
المظاهر العنف بيتعرضوا لها من العلاج
بالفنون ولا علاج بالفنون هنا مش بيتطلب
بس ادوات ادوات وغذاء لكن كمان انت
تتحدثين ربما يعني طبعا بالواقع الفلسطيني
هو صعب جدا ولكن بالواقع بشمال سوريا اصلا
ليس هناك من اي مقومات للحياه ممكن
بالواقع التركي ان يتم يعني احتضانهم
بطريقه تامه ولكن هناك المناطق شبه معدومه
كيف يمكن يعني احتضان الاطفال كي لا
يصبحون في المستقبل
شيء لا يريدونه لا اهله ولا المجتمع
رقم واحد يجب طمانه هؤلاء الاطفال بان هم
مش لوحدهم لانه اكثر ما يهدد هؤلاء
الاطفال انه المجهول ما فيش حاجه وضحكه
شرطي اليه في المقدمه انه لازم يبقى عارف
انه في حد هيدعمه انه مش لوحده انه هيلاقي
الدفا هيلاقي الماوى والماكل انه في لسه
اي حد هيفضل واقف جنبه ده في منتهى
الاهميه رقم اتنين انه يتعلم انه لوحده
الامور ما بتعديش لازم يتدفى في اللي
حواليه ويتشارك رقم ثلاثه انه يعني ويمكن
تجاه رقم واحد انه لو في اعراض مرضيه على
هؤلاء الاطفال وفي ادويه متاحه وفي اطباء
متخصصين لازم فورا الاولويه للاطفال اللي
بداوا يعانوا من الاضطراب او اللي تعرضوا
بشكل مباشر للسطر للصدمه فممكن الاعراض ما
تكون لسه بانت بس لازم يبتدوا ياخدوا
الادويه عشان نقفل الدواير اللي هتتعمل
جوه المخ قبل ما تتعمل فنحميهم من
رهاب مع بعض الكرب او الصدمه دي يمكن حاجه
نقول ان هناك احتياجات طبيه واحتياجات
يعني ميدانيه اليوم هناك احتياجات نفسيه
ايضا يجب على المنظمات غير الحكوميه وايضا
المنظمات الدوليه المساعده فيها بهذه
المناطق شكرا لك يا دكتوره رضوى عبد
العزيز سعيد عبد العظيم استشاريات الطب
النفسي على هذه المداخله
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره ونتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
استراليا تتوعد طهران بعد ضبط عمليه تجسس
ايرانيه على اراضيكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى الملف الاوكراني حيث
الوضع اصبح معقدا في مدينه بخموت مركز
المعارك في شرق اوكرانيا وفق ما اعترفت به
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اما الجيش الروسي
اعلن الاستيلاء على بلده جديده مواصلا
محاولاته لتطويق المدينه الحصن في دومباس
ومدينه بخموت التي كان عدد سكانها 70 الف
نسمه قبل الحرب دمرت الى حد كبير خلال
اكثر من سته اشهر من القتال الذي خلف ايضا
خسائر بشريه فادحه لدى الجانبين وعلى رغم
ان اهميه الاستراتيجيه موضوع تباين باتت
المدينه رمزا للصراع بين موسكو وكياف
للسيطره على هذه المنطقه الصناعيه بشرقي
البلاد
كشفت روسيا انها تختبر في عملياتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا طائرات مسيره لا
يمكن اعتراضها وتتميز المسيرات مسيرات
الاستطلاع الضاربه الروسيه الجديده رود
250 بسعرها المنخفض وسرعتها العاليه ولا
يمكن اعتراضها لانها لا تعتمد الملاحه
الفضائيه وتقطع هذه المسيرات في الوقت
الراهن لسلسله من الاختبارات في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
توقع وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ان تنفذ
اوكرانيا هجوما مضاده في الربيع مضيفا بان
دول ناتو ستواصل تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه
الدفاع الجوي والدبابات
سنبحث في مبادرات صناعيه تضمن استمراريه
دعمنا لاوكرانيا على المدى البعيد ايضا
سنبحث في مسؤوليات المتعلقه بالدعم الامني
الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي بلغ مستويات
تاريخيه اوكرانيا ملتزمه بان الدعم
العسكري الذي تتلقاه سيصل الى الجنود
الاوكرانيين على الجبهات هذا الاجتماع
ياتي في وقت حرج الكرملين مازال يراهن ان
بمقدوره ان يفرقنا لكن بعد عام من الحرب
مازلنا متحدين كما كنا سابقا
دخلت كاميرا العربيه قاعده عسكريه بلا
روسيا في مدينه بريستال القريبه من الشريط
الحدوديه البيلاروسي البولندي الاوكراني
حيث تجري منسك تدريبات لقوات الانسان
والهجوم الجوي على خلفيه الصراع بين موسكو
وحلفائها والغرب التفاصيل مع الزميل عبد
الجواد الرشد من هناك
حليف الكريم الاول يكشف عن قدرات بعض
جنوده العسكريه بعد مرور عام على الصراع
في اوكرانيا ما هي هذه القوات وما هي
قدراتها وكيف تجري تدريباتها العسكريه
العربيه اول فريق يدخل الى القاعده 38
للانزال والهجوم الجوي على الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه والبيلاروسيه
البولنديه
عشرات الجنود البيلاروسيين تبعثروا في
باحه الميدان العسكري ولكل منهم مهمته
الخاصه
[تصفيق]
نحن القوات البيلاروسيه مستعدون دوما
للدفاع عن بلادنا مهما كانت الظروف صعبه
ومهما تغيرت المهمات القتاليه
خطط الهجوم الجوي ظهرت بوضوح خلال عمليات
التدريب مهام عده لرفع قدرات القوات
تقوم الان بعض فرق الانزال باجراء محاكاه
للسيطره على منطقه حدوديه من مهامها انشاء
خط دفاع حسب روايه القائمين لحمايه حدود
البلاد
نحن نفتخر بكوننا احفاد ابطال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولهذا نحتفظ في مدخل
قاعدتنا بالكثير من قطع اجدادنا العسكريه
في الداخل معرض سنوي لذكرى الاجداد مهمه
تحضير طويله مرتبطه بعمر الازمه بين موسكو
والغرب عبد الجواد الروشت العربيه بريست
لن نقف مكتوب فيه الايدي استراليا تتوعد
ايران بعد ضبط عمليه تجسس ايرانيه على
اراضيها وفي التفاصيل كشفت وزاره الداخليه
الاستراليه ان ناشطا ايرانيا استراليا كان
مشاركا في تظاهرات تضامنيه مع حركه
الاحتجاج التي اندلعت بعد وفاه شاب مهسا
اميني في سبتمبر استهدفته عمليات التجسس
الايرانيه الداخليه الاستراليه اكدت انها
لن تتسامح مع اطلاق اطلاق تحت اي ظرف من
الظروف مع محاولات انظمه اجنبيه عرقله
التظاهرات السلميه او تشجيع العنف او
اسكات الاراء
[موسيقى]
وفي ملف الاجسام الطائره المجهوله قال
البيت الابيض انه لا توجد اي جهه اعلنت
مسؤوليتها عن الاجسام التي تم اسقاطها
مضيفا انه لا مؤشرات على ارتباطها ببرنامج
تجسس صيني وقال مسؤولون في الجيش الامريكي
انهم غير متاكدين كيف تمكنت هذه الاجسام
المجهوله من البقاء في وضعيه تحليق دائم
بعد ايام من الغموض قررت الاداره
الامريكيه الاجابه على بعض الاسئله
المتكرره والمتعلقه بالاجسام المجهوله
التي تم اسقاطها في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
الاجابات لم تكن شافيه مع الاعتراف ان
الكثير من المعلومات لا زالت مجهوله
فعمليه انتشال الحطام لم تتم حتى اللحظه
كريم جانبيار المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
شددت
انا اؤكد ان لا وجود لطبيعه فضائيه او
مخلوقات فضائيه متورطه بموضوع هذه الاجسام
دعوني اكرر ان لا صله بالكائنات الفضائيه
على الاطلاق
اما المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
فاختار توجيه الاتهامات الى اداره الرئيس
ترامب في محاوله لتحديد النظر عن التطورات
لازلنا لا نعلم الكثير عن هذه الاجسام
ولكن ما اود الاشاره اليه فهو ان عددا من
هذه الاجسام مره فوق بلادنا والاداره
السابقه لم ترصدها نحن فعلنا ذلك رصدناها
واسقطناها الجيش الامريكي اسقط ثلاثه
اجسام مجهوله في المجال الجوي لامريكا
الشماليه في غضون ثلاثه ايام الجسم الاول
اعلن عن اسقاطه يوم الجمعه في الاسكا ما
نعرفه عنه حجمه اصغر من البالون الصيني
الاول وهو بحجم سياره صغيره وغير ماهول
بالاضافه طبعا الى الجسم الثاني الذي اسقط
في كندا له شكل واسطواني واسقطته طائره اف
22 امريكيه في الاراضي الكنديه لنصل الى
الجسم الذي اسقط يوم الاحد في ولايه
الامريكيه وادى لاغلاق المجال الجوي فوق
بحيره هورون وهو الاغرب من بين الاجسام
السابقه فهو هيكل مثمن الاضلاع له خطوط
متدليه ولا توجد حموله يمكن تمييزها ولا
مؤشره على امتلاكه قدرات للمراقبه على
الرغم من عدم استبعاد ذلك وتم اسقطه من
طائره اف 16 امريكيه
الغموض ياجج نظريات المؤامره بشكل كبير
فموضوع الاجسام المشغوله ورطه ثلاثه
حكومات حتى اللحظه بالاضافه الى اغلاق
المجال الجوي لاربع ولايات امريكيه على
مدى عده ايام واليوم الصين تتحدث عن رصدها
لجسم مجهول فوق منطقه البحر الاصفر الذي
اعتبرته واحدا من عشرات البالونات
الامريكيه التي رصدتها منذ 2022
من غير المرجح ان هذا صحيح لو رصدت السينو
سابقا هذه الاجسام لكانت اسقطتها وعرضتها
واستخدمت كل القنوات الدبلوماسيه لتقدم
شكوى ضد الولايات المتحده في الامم
المتحده ومجلس الامن منذ لحظه اكتشافها
تبقى تداعيات رصد هذه الاجسام مرتبطه
بالحطام الذي تحاول السلطات الامريكيه
الحصول عليه فحتى اللحظه عمليه الانتشار
تواجه معوقات كثيره مثل الطقس والمساحات
الجغرافيه الواسعه بالاضافه الى الدمار
الذي يمكن ان يكون لاحقها جراء قصفها
بالصواريخ
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
الاجسام الطائره المجهوله الهويه تهديد
غامض جديد استيقظت عليه الولايات المتحده
وعليها تحديد ماهيتها ومن ارسلها ومده
بقاء هذه الاجسام في الاجواء الامريكيه
تقول هنا تايمز البريطانيه اجهزه
المخابرات الامريكيه برمتها متاهبه لدراسه
الصور التي تم التقاطها في الساعات التي
سبقت اسقاط الطائرات المقاتله للاجسام
الثلاثه الغامضه التي حلقت بالمجال الجوي
لامريكا الشماليه حتى الان مشاهدينا يبدو
انه لا توجد استنتاجات نهائيه والحقيقه
الوحيده الواضحه هي ان الاجسام الثلاثه لم
تكن مثل بالون التجسس الصيني هي اصغر
بكثير اي بحجم سياره صغيره كما نشاهد هنا
كما وصفها طبعا ايضا البنتاجون حيث تراوح
ارتفاع التحليق في اجواء الولايات المتحده
بين 20 و40 الف قدم احد الاجزاء او
الاجسام الطائره كان اسطوانيه الشكل وهو
عباره عن بالون معدني صغير يحمل شحنه
صغيره معلقه فيه وتم اسقاطه بالقرب من
مواقع امريكيه حساسه بحسب السلطات
الامريكيه وتحديدا في ولايه اما الثالث
فكان على شكل اوكتاجون ايسوماني الزوايا
والاضلاع ولديه خطوط مفصله ومتصله ببعضها
البعض كما نشاهد هنا ولكن الجسم الثاني لم
يحدد كيف كان شكله والجدير ذكره هنا ان
البنتاجون لم يستبعد ان تكون هذه الاجسام
قادمه من خارج كوكب الارض ولكن البيت
الابيض شدد على ان واشنطن لم تسجل اي
مؤشرات على نشاط مخلوقات فضائيه في حوادث
الاجسام الطائره المجهوله الهويه في
الاجواء الامريكيه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
كانت كشفت في وقت سابق عن اكثر من 500
بلاغ تم
وتم تابع لاجسام طائره مجهوله في اجواء
البلاد تم اكتشافها من خلال الشيفات قديمه
تعود الى فتره امتدت الى 20 سنه بدورها
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا كشفت العام
الماضي انها اختارت 16 شخصا للمشاركه في
الدراسه التي طال انتظارها حول الظواهر
الجويه غير المحدده والتي يشار اليها
مشاهدينا باسم الاجسام الطائره المجهوله
ولا جواب طبعا حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى ملف الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا اربعه اشخاص على قيد الحياه تمكنت
فرق البحث والانقاذ من اخراجهم من وسط
الركام وذلك بعد مرور ثمانيه ايام على
وقوع الزلزال كما افادت وكاله الاناضول
بانقاذ سيده من تحت الانقاذ بعد مضيء اكثر
من 200 ساعه في ولايه هاتاي جنوبي تركيا
قالت نائبه المفوض السامي لشؤون اللاجئين
خلال تفقدها للمناطق التي دمرها الزلزال
شمالي سوريا ان الزلزال تسبب بتشريد مئات
الاشخاص عن منازلهم وهم بلا ماوى فنتابع
هناك عدد كبير من الاشخاص الذين ليس لديهم
منازل الان لقد واجهوا بالفعل اثني عشر
عاما من الازمه وهذا الدمار يضاعف معاناه
الاف السوريين مجددا
قال وزير الطوارئ الروسيه الاكساندر
كورنيكوف ان الرئيس الروسي قرر سحب فرق
الانقاذ الروسيه من مناطق الكارثه في
سوريا وتركيا
يجري حاليا الانتهاء من عمليات البحث
والانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
المتضررتين من الزلزال لذلك قرر الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سحب الفرق الروسيه
من مناطق الكارثه
نهايه التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
210 ساعات على زلزال تركيا وسوريا حصيله
الضحايا تلامس 41 الف قتيل وفرق الانقاذ
تعثر على مزيد من الناجين
وصدمات نفسيه قد تلاحق الناجين من الزلزال
[موسيقى]
مرتزقه تضيق القناع على باخماطم تتوقع
مفاجاه اوكرانيا ومفاجاه مضاده في الربيع
بعد سيل من الاتهامات البيت الابيض يستبعد
ارتباط الاجسام التي تم اسقاطها ببرنامج
تجسس صيني
مشاهدينا الى هنا ناتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره والان الى 360
مع الزميله راويه راويه ماذا لديك اهلا بك
ليال فيما يخص زلزال تركيا وسوريا سنتحدث
مع مختص حول اسباب
انهدام مباني دون اخرى وطبعا ملف الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه حاضره